great
Graaff noon welcome to the National
Press Club my name is Nick Ryan I'm the
senior Washington correspondent here for
the Detroit News and also president of
the National Press Club and this today's
panel discussion is the second part of a
great two-day event here last night many
of you saw the movie the screening of
the movie Black Hawk Down and today
we'll hear a panel discussion about it
and I would like to here to introduce
you to today's moderator who's Pat's
fløyen a former bureau chief and war
correspondent for Newsday Pat has a
lengthy resume but because of the
shortage of time I just want to mention
a couple of things he won the Pulitzer
Prize for international reporting in
1992 for his coverage of Desert Storm
the Persian Gulf War and it's aftermath
and Pat also wrote extensively about the
Somalian campaign he was there for the
deployment of American troops and later
interviewed many of the wounded the
movie portrays after they were moved to
Germany so let me introduce to you Pats
lion I wanted to tell you today we're
going to be talking about Black Hawk
Down which realistically recreates the
slaughter on the streets of Mogadishu on
October 8 1983 nineteen American
soldiers died between 700 and 1,000
supporters of Somali warlord Mohamed
Farah Aidid were killed and wounded in
another age rudyard kipling would have
written a poem about the 13 hour
firefight something along the lines of
the tribute to the fuzzy-wuzzy they were
warriors with short swords who destroyed
a British army unit in the Sudan it was
part of a British punitive expedition to
capture the Mahdi culminated with the
Battle of Omdurman where general
Kitchener's modern cannon slaughtered
the assorted Sudanese those punitive
expeditions to squash various upstarts
against Queen Victoria's reign resulted
in Kipling's lines that stretched from
the Sudan to Afghanistan we're gonna den
was watering the Redcoats on the
Northwest Frontier today's hunt for
Osama bin Laden has all
all the earmarks of a punitive
expedition just as did the hunt for
Farah Aidid in Somalia nine years ago I
can almost guarantee you some sort of
film will emerge about US forces
changing bin Laden the most loathsome of
terrorists Black Hawk Down which I saw
last night shows you how Americans and
Somalis died today I hope to tell you
briefly why they died didn't give some
context of the film I was in Somalia
shortly after President Bush the senior
ordered 25,000 US troops and marine and
Army soldiers to preserve UN sponsored
food relief programs the food
distribution been caught up in the Civil
War
I found the US ambassador Robert Oakley
pursuing a Somalia wide ceasefire with
the leading warlord Farah Aidid the
commander of American forces at that
time was Marine General Robert Johnson
who was also seeking compromise not
confrontation with Aidid general Johnson
imported IDs son Hassan as chief
interpreter for the Marines at the time
Aidid son was in California and a member
of a marine reserve unit the wooing I of
Aidid led all combatants to the brink of
a peace agreement to be signed under US
auspices in May of 1993 but all these
diplomatic niceties stopped abruptly
when President Bill Clinton took over he
was a vocal opponent of the Vietnam War
and went to sub lengths as did most of
our current crop of political leaders to
elude the draft the president as
president he was determined to have
other countries share the burden of
dirty wars in the month after its
inauguration Clinton sent a Secretary of
State to meet with the UN Secretary
General who then was Boutros
boutros-ghali Warren Christopher pledged
American support for a UN effort there
now Boutros boutros-ghali many have you
forgotten him but he was a veteran
left-wing Egyptian politician
who gave Clinton opportunity in response
to Clinton's offer support of the UN
operation to a point the chief of the UN
mission in Somalia Clinton and his
national security advisor Tony Lake
picked US Navy Admiral jonathan how very
quickly a harder line developed toward
Aidid and it was signaled by the UN
Ambassador from the United States
Madeleine Albright Boutros boutros-ghali
was no stranger to Somali clan battles
while still in the Egyptian government
galle backed saeed bar as President of
Somalia during the Cold War gali and
Saeed bar had sided with the Soviet
Union an establishing military bases
throughout Somalia it resulted in the
United States
targeting Somalia in the Horn of Africa
as a flash point in the Cold War now he
was one of the first to oppose the
elevation of Farah Aidid as leader of
Somalia and now as general secretary and
with an American support Boutros
boutros-ghali had the leverage to attack
his old foe for Aidid very quickly
however priorities between the United
Nations and the United States began to
diverge under pressure from Congress
Clinton embarked on a program of
withdrawal from Somalia more than 25,000
troops left by August of 1993 but galle
had won support from the clintons
national security staff and the State
Department to oust Aidid opposed to any
further intervention was a Defense
Department General Colin Powell chairman
of the Joint Chiefs and Marine general
Joseph hor who netted Central Command
was in charge of operations in Somalia
hunting down Aidid was virtually
impossible because of a lack of
intelligence general hor argued
Clinton's national security advisor Tony
Lake used [ __ ] complained about the
lack of intelligence to dispatch an even
larger group of CIA agents to Mogadishu
once there however they had no luck in
tracing Aidid just as Horde predicted
then the CIA complained that even if
they found him there was the dwindling
number of US soldiers there couldn't
catch him couldn't grab him just not
within their capability but galley
admiral how the CIA ambassador albright
antonio lake all urged clinton to keep
chasing aidid and show the influence of
the united nations and the United States
to bring this warlord to justice they
had they wanted to have the Army Special
Forces the Green Berets who
traditionally provide muscle for CIA
operations to come and hunt down Aidid
in turn the Green Berets are supported
by the US Army Rangers and as you will
see in the film
they're very elite infantry force the
CIA even had plans to what to do with
Aidid once they caught him they had a
ship standing offshore in Kenya it was
going to be filled with judges provided
by the CIA to try and indict Aidid on
genocide but Powell and [ __ ] continued
to oppose this operation [ __ ] argued
that chances were one in four of
capturing Aidid and even if he was
captured it would make no difference as
his followers would continue the civil
war
Clinton sided with a military event soon
changes to Clinton's mind and striking
back against this pressure Aidid
soldiers ambushed and killed 24 UN
peacekeepers Pakistani army troops u.s.
army troops the US troops struck back
with army gunships spraying Aidid
supporters with automatic weapons
Clinton grew queasy at the unintended
deaths of women and children from
helicopter attacks it was just the sort
of American tactics in Vietnam that led
a younger Clinton to oppose the war by
August of 1993 Aidid up the ante this
time he killed American soldiers four
were killed and six had been wounded by
detonated mines mines detonated by
command Clinton issued orders and
and [ __ ] reluctantly agreed the Rangers
and Delta ports were dispatched August
22 horse prediction of a failure seemed
accurate eight days later CIA Delta
Force and the Rangers all swooped in on
a target in Mogadishu and snatched
someone who looked quite a bit like
Aidid the trouble was he worked for the
United Nations Defense Secretary les
aspin didn't complain he said we looked
like the gang that can't shoot straight
there were five more ill-fated missions
to catch Aidid and all failed
indeed responded with roadblocks and
confrontation with UN forces once again
army helicopters sprayed the area's 20
millimeter cannon killing a number of
women and children and the mobs not
intentionally but that's what happens in
those sort of conflicts it produced an
uproar in Congress and former President
Jimmy Carter who knew Aidid personally
finally persuaded Clinton to abandon the
hunt in Mogadishu Clinton revealed his
shift in policy in the September 27th
speech in the United Nations there would
be a u.s. effort to seek a peace
agreement that would include Aidid he
announced at the same time however he
was covering his political abets just on
the off chance that the CIA and Delta
Force might succeed before the diplomacy
got underway the hunt for Aidid remained
on what was turned the second of a
two-track policy six days later Clinton
and Delta Force ran out of luck during
the seventh and final effort to catch
Aidid that effort is portrayed in the
film Black Hawk Down not mentioned in
the film however is the bitterness
toward Clinton and others felt by some
families who lost sons and daughters so
a lot of one to know who they were dying
for they're dying for a vendetta for
Boutros boutros-ghali a mistake by
clinton's national security staff the
CIA these are some of the questions that
the film should raise in your mind now I
want to go ahead and see in the audience
who has some questions for the gentlemen
of the table
would you go up to the microphone please
you've given us a pretty good background
but I still have a question in my mind
for those who made the film and advised
it and that is this in the American
public's eyes this was pretty much of a
fiasco at the time but in the movie
those who participated in the mission
seemed to feel that it was a success as
a mission so I'd like to know if you
could address that disconnect any of you
who want to address that particular
issue I'll talk about it I think that a
lot of people have confused the
political disaster that pretty much
defines our investment or deployment to
Somalia with the military mission on
this particular day
and I think that very frequently the
American public does confuse military
action with policy our policy in Somalia
at that point in the summer of 1993 was
to try to remove Mohamed Farah Aidid
from the political equation in Mogadishu
so that you could form a coalition
government and there would be some
stability left there that that country
could sort of get on its feet and
there's no question that because of this
battle and the losses of the
unanticipated loss of American life that
the political decision was made to
abandon that mission and so in a sense
you know are a whole effort in Somalia
other than the successful intervention
to end the famine in 1992 ended in
failure and that's why I think most
people think of this whole episode as a
failure but what by what I did in the
book Black Hawk Down and what the movie
does is focus on the military mission of
October 3rd and 4th during which this
task force went out to find two
lieutenants top figures in I deeds inner
circle target them arrest them and carry
them out of the city they accomplished
that mission
they clearly encountered far greater
difficult
and hostility than they'd ever imagined
the scale of the firefight was enough to
end the whole effort but they succeeded
and most of them fought their way out of
that city alive and so the military men
regarded their mission as successful on
that day and that I think helps you to
understand why so many of the men who
fought in this battle have felt so
betrayed and abandoned or misunderstood
I think by the public perception oh yeah
and it's worth noting that the the
Clinton administration had decided not
to send the ac-130 Spectre gunship with
the force because it was a very
high-profile weapon these units trained
to do operations like these with that
plane high enough overhead that it's
basically out of range for anyone on the
ground and there's every reason to
believe that if they'd had that weapon
when they went out that day that there
wouldn't have been this tremendous loss
of life either Somali or or American
which which the military commanders
requested in their in their package and
were denied Mark Bowden is the author of
the book Black Hawk Down on which the
movie is based over on the end here we
have Colonel Tom Mathews and Colonel Lee
Van Arsdale Tom I know was with the unit
and the operation you want to talk to
some of these points well quite a beret
that was touched on there there's a
political level to this from a tactical
level for a military operation on that
day we kick their butt we accomplish the
mission we went after two people we got
them what people don't understand
oftentimes is that when you employ the
military it's an element of power of
this nation that you can choose to elect
to employ there's diplomatic there's
political with that there's
informational there's economic things
you can do but if you decide to employ
the US military there's a cost and a
consequence for the employment there you
are conducting combat operations the
media have withdrawn from the country
for a number of reasons if you go back
and check American media was not there
and the American public didn't realize
what's not getting reported on the
conduct of North
operations in that country in that city
at that time so there was a lack of
awareness that's what people reacted to
when they saw the visual results but
there's a consequence when you employ
the military when you employ the
military you better be able to stand up
and accept responsibility for them I'd
like to add briefly it is a common
misperception that the six previous
missions were to apprehend Aidid that's
incorrect they were to take out radio
Mogadishu one of his very well used
propaganda machines to apprehend osman
ATO is Minister of Finance and several
other things these were successful
missions you can't ever hidden someone
if you don't know where he is we never
knew or Aidid was so we decided to
consciously go after his infrastructure
take that away from him to bring him out
that strategy was working the 3rd of
October as Tom said we the mission was
not to apprehend Aidid who was Daron two
of his top lieutenants
we got them along with 22 of our
bodyguards brought him back more or less
in one piece although they were fired up
pretty well by their own countrymen I
remember well the reports that came out
immediately after the fourth of October
you couldn't see a headline that didn't
have a word debacle or failure or
bungled mission in it and that
misperception continues today so that's
one reason I'm very grateful that this
movie is being made to help counter that
perception that it was a failure to
baccala bungled mission none of the
above producer of the film could you
speak to these issues I mean you
invested your time and talent I love to
make movies about heroic deeds and the
Brotherhood a man and and and things
that you know we hope we find in our
daily lives and you know especially
these young men who fought and gave up
their lives for the man next to them
those are those are deeds that I feel
are just wonderful in humanity and when
I read marks book and I read it in 97 in
the galley form before it was published
it gave me an insight looking into this
battle and something that I knew nothing
about other than what I saw on CNN were
the you know the young Rangers our Delta
who were being dragged through the
streets that's all I knew about
Mogadishu until I read this book and
this book in
learn me enlighten me and showed that I
felt as a filmmaker I had to set the
record straight that this wasn't a
bungled mission by these really
courageous men who went in there and
they don't make policy they enforce it
they're given a mission and in this
mission they had one hand tied behind
their backs they didn't have the assets
they're required to do this as
successfully as it ended up being even
though we lost American lives but any
time as Tom was saying you employ the
military there's a great possibility
they're going to be American casualties
if we put it in today's terms if if Ben
Laden and we wanted to capture two of
his key lieutenants the men who have the
high prices on their head we went in
there tomorrow got two of them killed a
thousand of the al-qaeda and lost 19 men
and be tragic that we lost the 19 men
but we accomplished our mission mission
and the casualties were much greater on
the other side than on our side so I
think those are things we all have to
think about it's all about context and
the American public since the media
wasn't there we're not aware of what was
going on not prepared for this that's
why they thought it was a debacle we
have another question here was there
very much discussion and any
disagreement on how to portray Islam in
the film and how do you see the
influence and power of Islam in Somalia
today as compared to the time period
that is portrayed in the film first of
all we used marks book as the Bible we
tried to give a portrayal of what Mark
wrote and you can speak about that issue
and what you wrote but what we tried to
do is show the movie from the
perspective of the American soldiers and
what they were going through you have to
pick a point of view and Mark's book
took the point of view of the men who
were involved in the mission you know
the battle took 18 hours the history of
Somalia is you know will take years to
come out and tell you the true story of
what really went on there because these
wars have been going on for centuries
over there so that never entered into
our filmmaking process
it was in your book which no I mean
Somalia is an Islamist country item I'm
not an expert on Somalia I studied it
and I was there in 1997 to do research
for the book my impression of the time
that I spent there was that while it was
an Islamic country it was not a
fundamentalist extremist kind of Islam
that's practiced there it's much more
mainstream
there were fundamentalist schools which
had basically come in to fill a vacuum
because there was no otherwise there
were no schools there being no
government and no laws or anything of
any consequence so it certainly was a
potential place in 1997 when I visited
potentially a fertile soil for
fundamentalist Islamists but my
impression of the Somalis who I met who
were allied with one warlord or another
was that they were primarily secular
they were primarily concerned about
rebuilding their country and
reestablishing trade and trying to make
money was what they were trying to do
question back here
Rebecca Christie a reporter with Dow
Jones Newswires thank you for coming I
wanted to ask mr. Bowden and also
Colonel Mathews and Colonel Van Arsdale
about your perceptions of the contact or
lack of contact between the civilian
world in the military world you guys
were talking about the difference
between a military action and a policy
decision and it seems like unlike in
previous generations there really isn't
the day-to-day contact between regular
civilians and regular military people
the military is this big abstract group
of superheroes and from the military
perspective civilians are these you know
kind of weirdos who have long hair and
live somewhere else and so I guess I'd
be interested in your views and how this
movie could affect that or maybe how the
movie just serves a different purpose
there's a big divide like that until
your son like mine joins the Marines and
suddenly there's not quite so big a gap
as you might think but I'd like for Lee
and Tom to address that well the funny
military were funny civilian before they
get into know
Terry so it's really from the same base
and they turn into civilians after that
but I do think that it is a consequence
of having a volunteer army there are our
real social benefits I think that derive
from a national draft we've seen that
out of world war two I think the roots
of the civil rights movement grew out of
World War two and many other things I
think it's a great social leveler the
experience of a national draft but on
the other hand you know holding a draft
is there are huge social consequences to
that I mean it's obviously an
extraordinarily intrusive thing in in
person in people's private lives so I
personally think that there shouldn't be
a draft like that unless it's a national
emergency and it's required but the the
what the cost of that is that you do
have a sort of a chasm between civilians
who have never had any experience with
the military who lacked really a
fundamental understanding and I would
put myself in that category because
prior to running this book I had never
written about the military I had never
served in the military and it's been a
tremendous education for me so I do
think that it's something that we as a
democracy have to cope with and and I
think the military frankly does a very
poor job of allowing journalists access
to military action which i think is
essential in a democracy for so people
understand you know who's out there
doing the fighting what they're doing
you know what the nature of it is so I
think that that could be improved and I
also think frankly that journalists in
the last 30 or 40 years have had a very
sour skeptical attitude toward the
military most of what we've written and
reported about the military and at least
on a on a high level of visibility has
been have been stories of disaster or
atrocity or scandal which are all very
legitimate stories but there are also
stories of tremendous sacrifices
difficulties that people face in your
name and in mine and I think too few of
those stories have been told it's about
information I might add too it's about
information
and there's not a military operation
that goes on today that there's not and
there's a hell of a lot of an education
of the military and in the military
schooling system about the impact of the
media and the effect of information out
there if you just think today about who
you see getting standing up behind the
microphone briefing America today about
what's going on you see the military
representations wellness of the the
civilian so I think they're they're
certainly an awareness in the military
about that very fact right there and
there's a concerted effort to make sure
that that that flow is good and that
there's an understanding out there to
try to bridge that gap question back
here
Jim Jim wolf Reuters mr. Bowden I'm
curious about your experience in dealing
with the army for access to the
underlying document as well as
interviews with the participants and the
cases of Colonel Mathews and Colonel Van
Arsdale and the Army's attitude towards
making you available originally and how
the whole process of disclosure took
place especially for Delta which of
course the Army to this day declines to
acknowledge the existence of officially
well it's it's I probably don't have
enough time here for me to fully answer
that question but in a nutshell
initially the military was not helpful
at all in my requests I was able through
the father of one of the young Rangers
who died in the battle Jim Smith who was
in Long Branch New Jersey introduced me
to a number of Jaime's his son Jaime's
buddies from the Ranger unit and and I
was able then because I knew exactly who
I wanted to talk to and I knew that they
were willing to talk to me I was able to
get a bunch of interviews set up with
Rangers down at Fort Benning which is
what really launched me on the story and
they also set up a really important set
of interviews the media fairs for you
know
a Special Operations Command let me
interview Michael Durant and a couple of
the pilots at Fort Campbell and beyond
that the effort was entirely unofficial
once I knew the first dozen soldiers and
it interviewed them they were able to
give me the names of their buddies who
many of whom were now out of the army
and much more free to talk and so I
pursued that Avenue basically going from
one soldier to the next and each soldier
would have two or three more people so
before long I had scores of soldiers
who'd been in part of this battle to
interview I later on was able after I
did research in Somalia was lucky enough
to have individuals who were in command
positions who decided to help me and a
number of them agreed to be interviewed
some of them off the record or on the
record a number of them had
documentation like videotape audiotape
transcripts documentation that they were
willing to share with me and I think
that happened probably because there was
such a feeling that this episode was so
poorly misunder poorly understood that
it had been forgotten and there was a
real desire on the part of the men who
had participated that the truth come out
I never had a person share information
with me who asked for any restraints or
restrictions on what I was going to
write only that you tell the truth and
that you try to be as accurate as you
can be and I tried to you know follow
that when I wrote it but that in a
nutshell is how I did it well Delta
which as you know the Army doesn't
acknowledge exists I did meet a person
who gave me a list of names of men who
had been in that unit and who had fought
in the battle but who were no longer in
that unit so who technically could talk
to me if they could get permission or in
some cases they were out of the army but
there is a personal code within that
unit where men don't talk about what
they do and I went down that list of
names that I was given and I called an
it was a in an effort to leave no stone
unturned you know I called them all and
I would get guys on the phone and would
say you got the wrong guy pal or sorry
can't help you and they would hang up
but one of the one of the men on the
list much to my delight and surprise
sergeant Paul how hesitated for a long
time on the phone and said I really
would like to talk to you and he had
lost some of his best friends in this
battle he felt that there were really
fundamental misunderstandings in the
army and in the public and he wanted to
take advantage of the opportunity to
make this book as accurate as it could
be and I'm indebted to him you know I
think he did me a great service and I
think he did a great public service by
doing it but he did it at some cost to
his relationships with other guys in
that in that unit I want to ask Ridley
Scott the director a question on that
point you have uh you can pick and
choose the films you want to direct why
did you pick this one and what
cooperation did you get from the
American military well I think I'm the
only English person in this room and and
so that's what I mean sitting done what
do you make this movie this is very
interesting all this political overviews
I only remember the incident because I
was in London at the time I don't so
much live here I live more in Europe and
I think we get more extensive coverage
on on European CNN we tend to hit the
foreign side of things even even more
than they do here and so I watched this
process that's true I watch this process
I'm a kind of news junkie so watch my 20
minutes every morning to about two or
three different channels BBC ITN CNN and
so this information open and close like
a flash I remember just seeing bodies
going to the streets they look white and
I resum the European that's in Africa
somewhere and it that door open enclosed
in a flash then a couple of days later
there was more to that
the pilot called Durant was who had been
negotiated for was let to go I think 11
days later 11 days after that event and
it was over here did they gone tomorrow
and that passed me by that was in of
course 90 but but that would be shortly
after 90 he would hit the news almost
immediately I've reread 93 93 but the
the fifth or the sixth 93 then you know
I'm a filmmaker so well I essentially
look for a good tale like a good
journalist looks for a good tale good
story and that's what it's fundamentally
all about I'm in the business of
entertainment primarily and I've never
really tackled anything so a serviço
realistic before and that in itself
became a great challenge to see if I
could tell the story without being
sentimental trying to be as accurate as
possible and the problem is because the
definition of the scale of the project
tends to lead us down a path of cost so
it ain't it ain't a small cheaper v it's
and at the same time I do think they got
a good bargain price for this film and
you know with the information that marks
book then Ferriss with I and you know
there wasn't one script that particular
moment I came aboard and got into this
with Jerry and then we started discusses
went right down right through back
through the book start to rework the
process and because I felt as always you
know fact is far stranger than fiction
and all you gotta do is stick with the
facts and the rest the truth will out
and the truth will be most powerful and
at the end of the day the questions have
been fired at me recently were how old
you think this movie's going to play
well at the moment you can't get in this
film and I know we open wide on Friday
but we and that you know that there's a
hat the general public have a habit of
sensing the truth and sensing that they
are being informed and having a sense of
value to that and that's what got into
the film one last question back here
my name is John Aquino the film credits
end with the statement that although it
is based on a true story certain
characters are composites or fictitious
and any resemblance to people living or
dead is purely coincidental given the
controversy about films that are bate
have been based on real-life events such
as the Beautiful Mind a perfect storm
how mr. Scott and mr. Bruckheimer do you
reconcile fictitious and based on actual
events you got a hundred characters in a
book you can't tell a film about 100
characters and normally normal drama
lets it in simplistic terms takes on you
no this is a good guy and there's a bad
guy in all this is good this is a
there's a there's a woman and there's a
man and the story of vols and revolves
around that process here we've got a
hundred characters and we have to
distill that into a screenplay form and
the hard thing was how small how
tight-knit group can I possibly be for
the ordinance to be able to you know
take it in because you stand in you know
a very precarious position of a switch
off factor in the audience where they
just lose the jigsaw puzzle one of the
hardest things of all on this from my
point of view was actually pinpointing
this down into a blueprint which is the
screenplay because that blueprint then
goes to everyone it's like a huge
instruction sheet apart from just the
actors and we never managed to get down
to the less than 37 people so other
people had interesting stories of the
hundred so you eventually have to be
selective and say I would love to take
this event from this character that from
that character and therefore you know
put into say one character three
different parts of three different
elements that's the you know that's the
fundamental rules of drama otherwise
you'd have been watching his massive
documentary and the cause and effect
process may have got very confusing
Ridley touched on one bottom-line issue
and I wanted to ask Jerry a bottom-line
question how was
the cooperation with the Defense
Department how did you find their
cooperation today get script approval
and did you have to pay them a certain
amount of money for the American units
you used in the film yesterday all the
above but no we got full cooperation
from the Defense Department through two
administrations William Cohen who was
the outgoing secretary defense was a big
fan of the book and and said he would
help us in any way to get the movie made
when we were making Pearl Harbor at that
time he was he was involved in that also
and knew we were making black Hawkins
and he'll ended his help to us and so
was the head of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff at the time general Shelton who
also was a big supporter of the book and
then when it moved to the Bush
administration we found Rumsfeld also I
guess a fan of the book and and the
military again a fan of Marc's work so
they were very cooperative and in giving
us the Rangers and the Blackhawks and
the little birds with a price tag of
course it's like a rate card you get a
red card for how many pilots how many
helicopters it's all based on the you
know the Defense Department's lending
their equipment and men to movie
companies and I think we paid in the
tune of 2.2 million dollars to the
government for the use of the men in
them and the equipment I think that's
about it we have one more question no
that's that's it and I want to thank the
members of the panel for their time and
their information and I hope the
audience enjoyed listening get a little
insight into Black Hawk Down thank you
very much thank you all for coming